salut aujourd'hui c'est un nouvel
épisode du boost brain avec laeticia de
la chaîne le corps la maison l'esprit il
ya un an jour pour jour j'ai rencontré
laetitia ici avec ce en provence dans
cet appartement et on leur fait ici un
an plus tard c'est un petit peu notre
pèlerinage le but du jeu de voir si avec
ma technique laetitia arrivera à retenir
un jeu de cartes dans sa tête c'est
parti ben brahim
[Musique]
fabien olicard va essayer de me rendre
intelligente c'est pas gagné devant ce
talent heures elle a essayé de
m'apprendre à droite et la gauche
c'était pacifique elle m'a dit ça dépend
de qui tu es mais bien sûr tout en bas
la main droite et rive gauche bousbaine
pour ceux qui ont suivi cette nouvelle
série que j'avais commencé à entamer
très légèrement à 2016 mais une plus
2017 avec l'asm a pour but d'apprendre
quelque chose à vous de vous donner une
astuce mais surtout que quelqu'un le
fasse en même temps comme ça ça vous
prouve que ça fonctionne et que vous
pouvez faire vous aussi ce qui est
plutôt cool le but du jeu c'est de
retenir un jeu de cartes en entier
d'accord je vais pas le faire en entier
parce que c'est trop long il ya deux
techniques à peau nette et je te
demander si tu connaissais le baril
mentaux indique non donc du coup on va
on va faire qu'une partie on va faire un
maximum de ce qu'on peut on va déjà se
créer un ballet mentale rapidement je te
dirai après tout à l'heure à quoi ça
sert j'aimerais que tu imagines un
endroit tu que tu connais
particulièrement bien à ma cuisine de
puiser si tu pars vers la gauche on va
faire le tour de ta cuisine de la gauche
vers la droite
attendu que tu veux mais dans le sens de
gauche à devoir attendre d'abord là ici
à tous les trucs avec les tasses les
assiettes les médical et acs les
délégations magazine ces matchs après en
phase où nous allons et vit la machine à
laver de trucs pour faire à manger dans
cet ordre là ailier machines à laver et
quoi et la plaque pour faire à manger
le blade depuis sont d'accord ensuite il
ya toute la partie qui donne sur mon
salon du caj
grande vitre qui dure en salle en vitre
s'est passé vite
sylvie d'accord ok et ensuite j'ai le
mur de la honte de ce nom je te parlais
tout à l'heure
hier tous les trucs de manger plus le
meuble avec le four voilà sauf que dans
le truc de tir dévié machin bon c'est
pas dans son sens à ces genres machine à
laver est bien d'accord donc d'abord
nationales avaient apprécié d'accord là
tu sais pas encore mais on vient de
créer un vrai mental très rapidement un
petit qui a plusieurs squats on va les
comptes et ensemble on a les tasses on a
donc d'abord la machine à laver ensuite
l'ailier le plaque de cuisson la vitre
et la machine pour le jour vous qui
selon la chaîne vous savez ce qui est
alimentaire si vous savez pas vous
regarder dans la playlist mémoire s'est
expliqué et c'est très utile à cette
imprimante avec six potes on va pouvoir
déposer des choses mentalement lapin
maintenant pour apprendre le jeu de
cartes
on va apprendre l'ordre des séquences
rouge noir c'est quelque chose que
j'avais expliqué il ya longtemps sur la
chaîne et en parlant avec des abonnés
mais peu de personnes osent essayer de
le faire parce qu'ils pensent que c'est
trop compliqué qu'est-ce que je pense
pas que ça ne marche pas donc on va le
faire ensemble on va la prendre des
séquences où il juste rouge et noir toi
après tu seras capable de dire rouge
noir rouge blanc noir rouge déjà pas mal
du tout ça c'est d'un noir c'est un
rouge sur le blitz est plus léger donc
c'est 0 samedi au quai de mater capable
de le faire maintenant je t'ai dit quant
à lui avec les à prendre trois par trois
et pour ça il ya plein de possibilités
différentes ça c'est toutes les
possibilités de séquences qui existe et
vesa on va convertir dans la tête avec
des chiffres le pain il est à droite
d'accord avec moi sur ces trois cartes
là on à 0,01 et le arrivé à droite la
droite allait toujours
ici il n'y a pas de rapport attali nac
ya pas par rapport à qui et à quoi c'est
que par rapport à toi la droite allait
là bas donc là le 1 la droite
tommy la droite ça commence par un d on
va penser à donald idées au milieu et
bien avec le m on va penser à lille ça
marche
ouais à gauche ça fait j'ai de gargamel
là on voit que les deux un switch à côté
ils encerclent en fait le rouge avec le
e2 encerclé on va faire quelque chose on
va faire excalibur
à ce stade la structure toujours fois
mois là il ya 3 1
on peut dire que c'est la version ultime
d1 1 1 à ses ultimes ultime c'est hulk
la guerre n'a 020 comme zorro là on en a
deux qui sont à droite deux à droite ça
fait d'aider comme dédé de la française
des jeux qui suit un petit cochon et les
deux à gauche ça fait 2 g
quand gg quand les jeunes les marques
son nom commentaires qu en fait mais ça
c'est pas visualisables un truc angers
j'ai moi j'ai la gorgone je pense
souvent la gordonne pour tous mais parce
que ces méduses la femme avec les
cheveux en 5.1 de méduses d'oublier des
pièces enregistrées
ça m'est déjà arrivé je prends les trois
premières cartes une 2-3 samedi au caire
sainement est ce que tu peux me dire
quelle image c'est ça alors attends il
ya deux de ce côté insurgés s'étaient
gargamel et gg je viens je t'avais dire
ça fait le truc des jeunes du lycée
masséna c'est la mecque des choses balas
l'accord donne des cheveux en cinq
langues exactement bien que des 0 g que
des heureux dans cette zone
exactement donc on a l'accord d'année
zorro à ce que jean allez je vous pousse
un peu le vice un autre et donc la table
et là c'était un dense était celui du
milieu et celui du milieu c'était milou
exactement pourquoi dans la zone on va
créer une action avec eux c'est ça qui
va être plus drôle dans le premier spot
de ta cuisine c'est à dire les tasses
quand tu rends sur la gauche où il passe
j'imagine on doit imaginer qu'ils
règlent ward michela d'accord qui a la
main avec tous ses cheveux en serpent
qui est dans la cuisine au niveau de
métal polymère ddas tu vois et allez
peut-être peut-être qu'elle a plusieurs
tasses calé tient comme ça il ya les
laisser reprendre ses shoots sont rares
voire dans les tasses carrément que lui
mais alors rien à voir comme ticket
hockey est juste à sa droite
toujours au niveau des tasses ya zéro
qu'elle a faite d euros qu'est la côte
est qui la regardent un match mais
qu'est ce qui fait qu'un prêt mais
qu'est ce que tu fais ta prenantes à vie
alors que c'est lui qui a un problème
parce qu'il est en train de tenir milou
en laisse
ok ok
[Musique]
on est toujours chez moi il se passe
toujours des trucs de fonds dans la
cuisine dans mon évier ya ming
quel tranquillou dans son petit bug qui
fait sa lettre mais ce qui s'est pas
rendu compte c'est qu'ils s'étaient mis
à l'intérieur de mon et filles où
j'avais des craintes et les serpents
pour le repas tu voi est certain de la
tête de méduse que j'allais goûter à un
après l'autre et là lui qui arrive dans
la cuisine et guy commence à gueuler
mais c'est quoi ce bordel dans l'évier y
avait les sapins
[Applaudissements]
le but après quand tu recherches auxerre
c'est d'aller dans ton pas le mental
doute à compliquer un peu les mantas
besoin que tu connaissais avec des
endroits on a défini un à six dans ta
cuisine tu vas aller dans son palais
mental tu vas voir les images les scènes
qui vont trop venir
il faut que tu déconnes csn en cartes
ensuite gorgone c'est quand y avait les
gigis gg danse et noir n'auront
exactement noir ivoire origine hongroise
unis ensuite on a zéro et zorro c'est
quand il ya des 0 du coup c'était où je
rejoins et un stand avec milou qu'est le
mec du milieu donc c'était rouge noir
rouge rouge médicaux mais d'être en
continu deuxième ça
la deuxième histoire c'était l'histoire
qui se passait dans la machine à laver
machette extérieurs' à un cercle
donc ça veut dire si je me suis dit que
c'était noir rouge noir rouge
ensuite on à donald qui sort le linge
est dommage c'était le des donc c'était
vers la base c'était rouge rouge et un
rouge rouge noir et un site
on a donc deux maxis en algérie voie à
la méduse et l'habitude c'était bien moi
je pense à gg en fait donc c'était bien
noir noir rouge moi dans mon évier vient
d'où tu viens me traduire tout de suite
mais l'eau oui comme ça tant que pour
vous faire voir si la démarche de
traduire tout sera ok donc dans mon
évier
il y à roches noires rouges qui en train
de faire libérer
mais en fait on se rend compte que à
l'intérieur de l'eau il ya aussi le noir
noir rouge rouge et la ja rule qui
arrive qui pète un câble et lui c'est le
luxe et le super fort si t'es pas le
nombre de victimes noires ok et alors
les derniers tu continues ouais c'est
l'histoire des chiens qui est pas une
histoire facile à raconter parce que
j'ai toujours des trois parties soient
d'accord dont elle était facile je m'en
souviens c'était noir attend c'était
rouge noir rouge rose noir rouge rouge
noir ou bleu hier mais 26,36 4 donc la
fin on a vu ça peut me servir à froid en
fait d'avoir presque
alors là c'est une application directe
pour faire les cartes où ça sert à rien
à part à s'entraîner à se faire des
images ou ou à ce qu'a raconté pour sa
part défier avec les captures mais le
but de ça c'est surtout de s'habituer à
faire du palais mentale à faire du
millage apposer des images etc
pour utiliser d'autres systèmes qui sont
plus sophistiqués et qui vont nous
permettre de revenir encore plus de
choses après n'être au moins ça donne un
sens quoi tu vois ok merci bas derrière
la maison esclaves rien et alors comment
tu as pu voir dans magazine il se passe
des trucs de fou du coup si tu veux
savoir ce qui s'est passé d'autres
les chiens qui sont entre les murs
les trucs à dans la machine à laver je
t'invite à venir voir sur ma chaîne
revient du berger mais j'ai redit le
corps la maison l'esprit je voulais
devenir dans la description évidemment
vous vous aussi
cliquez ici pour vous abonner à laetitia
ou aussi pour vous abonner à moi et si
vous avez aimé vous pouvez liker et
partagez et rendez vous bientôt sur -
début de semaine prochaine
ciao
[Musique]